cimetière débordé fermé enterrement dans
des fosses communes
la pandémie de coronavirus n'en finit
pas de ravager la bolivie où le
gouvernement semble dépassée dans les
foyers bolivien l'attenté longue pour
les familles avant que ne soit levé les
corps de leurs proches pour attirer
l'attention des autorités des services
funéraires de la ville de cochabamba
une famille a bloqué une rue avec un
cercueil le corps de la victime avait
passé six jours dans sa maison sans être
récupérés nous avons dû le sortir ce
matin pour l'exposer au regard de la
population dans toute son ampleur
parce que c'est là qu'ils l'emportent le
bureau du maire le bureau du gouverneur
afin qu'il puisse m'enterrer parce
qu'ils n'ont pas rendu possible jusqu'à
aujourd'hui l'enterrement mais sont-ce
là ici laissons cela se propager à tout
le monde à toutes les personnes nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix
les parents sont malades à la maison ils
ne sont pas venus se faire tester cela
fait plusieurs années que le système de
santé est montrée du doigt dans le pays
si les infrastructures publiques se sont
améliorées en 15 ans les hôpitaux eux
sont toujours dans un état lamentable
plusieurs établissements ont d'ailleurs
fermé leurs portes ces dernières
semaines du fait de la contagion d'une
grande partie du personnel de santé
j'ai appelé les ambulances pour qu'elles
viennent le voir pour qu'il ausculte
s'il vous plaît mon père manqué
d'oxygène ils n'ont pas pris la peine de
venir
je suis mineur que vais-je faire ma mère
est en état de choc elle est sensible
j'ai ici ma grand mère de 87 ans
maintenant ils ont juste insister pour
emmener mon père mon père n'est même pas
mort dignement et j'ai perdu mon père
mon frère et ma mère a perdu son mari
que va-t-on devenir
je ne sais pas ce que fait ce
gouvernement ils disent qu'ils font de
leur mieux
tout ce qu'ils peuvent faire c'est
parler mais ils ne font rien il y a de
plus en plus de personnes infectées de
plus en plus de morts est chaque fois
plus de souffrance ici en bolivie dans
les zones les plus 6
l'est du pays grand comme quasiment deux
fois la france pas de centre de santé ni
de mesures de confinement
les gens y meurent du coronavirus dans
l'indifférence du gouvernement central